ريال بيتيس يطلق مبادره انسانيه لذوي
الاحتياجات الخاصه
سياسي يتبادلان الاتهامات على الهواء
ونيوكاسل يودع لاعبه المتوفي بزلزال تركيا
هذه الاخبار وغيرها نقدمها لكم من العربيه
رياضه اهلا بكم
وقف فريق نيوكاسل وضيفه ليفربول دقيقه صمت
انحدادا على وفاه لاعب نيوكاسل وهاتاي
سبورت التركي السابق
كريستيسو بعد العثور على جثته امس تحت
انقاذ المبنى الذي كان يقتنه في هاتاي
التركيه وتوفي ادسو جراء الزلزال الذي ضرب
تركيا وسوريا مؤخرا
شهدت مباراه ريال بيتيس وبلد الوليد في
الدوري الاسباني العديد من الاجراءات لجعل
اللعبه اقرب لذوي الاحتياجات الخاصه من
الجماهير حيث ارتدى لاعب فيتيس في فتره
الاحماء قمصانا تحمل رموزا لمساعده
المشجعين الذين يعانون من عمل الوان كما
خصص النادي الاسباني مبادره استعراضيه بين
الشوطين شارك فيها اللاعبون بتر احد
اطرافهم بينما عرض نشيد فريق بيتيس الرسمي
بلغه الاشاره على شاشه عملاقه
تبادل لاعبه منتخب اسبانيا في السابق
جيرارد بيكي واكر كاسياس الاتهامات من
خلال احد البرامج وياتي الجدال على خلفيه
الاخطاء التحكيميه وانحياز الحكام
لبرشلونه وريال مدريد وكانت وسائل اعلام
الاسبانيه قالت ان برشلونه متهم بالفساد
ورشوه الحكام في الفتره ما بين 2016
و2018 وبدا اللاعبان في تبادل الاتهامات
وذكر حوادث بعينها حصلت في المباريات تؤكد
تواطئ الحكم كل ضده فريقه
انتقد مدرب استون فيلا حارس مرمى فريقه
ايميليانو مارتينيز بعد تسببه في هدف
ارسنال الرابع ضد فريق اثر خروج الحارس
الارجنتيني من مرمى في محاوله لادراك
التعادل بعدما استقبل هدفا قبلها بطريقه
ساذجه لتنهل عليك تعليقات جمهور ارسنال
ومنها كيف ساقنع اولادي بان هذا الرجل كان
بطل العالم قبل شهرين